new rules governing the openness and
transparency of high street banks will
come into force across the ehue ending
the practices of some to hide costs
impede the defection of customers and
block marginalized citizens from holding
accounts the steps just agreed by MEP s
were welcomed on those very same high
streets but some wanted even more
disability policy DT poor Nana BST I am
usually they'll consume it already - not
today or reduce only showers listen Jude
Machado shows me I pray for debilitating
workers as to your sink you ever going
to give for any piece this is about
modernization and transparency making
the banks often over elaborate and
confusing fee tariffs crystal clear it
becomes much more transparent for
consumers to compare prices on bank
accounts that's first first and foremost
secondly we also make it much easier for
them to switch their bank account so it
is really extending the consumer rights
that we have today also now to bank
accounts we hope that this directive
restores a little bit of the confidence
in the banking system I think that's
necessary the legislation also targets
support at around 50 million
marginalised citizens 10% of the --use
population who for one reason or another
can't open accounts if you are poor if
you are over in bed if you are jobless
it's difficult in many countries to get
an account but you need an account to
take part in daily business life it will
also push Europe closer towards the
completion of the single market but the
banking sector in the European Union is
really frequented and now I think it's
time to create single market in the
banking sector as well because mobility
is increasing MEP hope they can start
direct negotiations with member states
in January and hold a final plenary vote
by spring